in iowa the farm labor who was convicted
friday
in the abduction and murder of
20-year-old college student molly
tibbetts
is expected to be sentenced in july
tibbetts went out for a run
almost three years ago and never
returned the case fueled anger against
illegal immigration
adriana diaz reports christian
bahina rivera guilty of the crime of
murder in the first degree
the verdict came on the first full day
of deliberations
in a case that rocked the heartland he
knew where the body was
and that was a big piece of the
corroboration to his story
the disappearance of 20-year-old molly
tibbetts who was last seen on a jog in
july of 2018
consumed the town of brooklyn iowa
surveillance video of tibbetts and this
black malibu
led investigators to rivera the arrest
of rivera
an undocumented dairy worker became a
lightning rod over illegal immigration
rivera told investigators in 2018 that
he followed tibbetts who he found
attractive
and when she threatened to call police
he became angry
and blacked out later finding her body
in his trunk
he led police to her body in this
cornfield
your talent is god's gift to you mollie
tibbetts captured the collective soul of
america
people see in mollie their own daughters
their
own girlfriend their own sister
prosecutors said tibbetts family is
relieved
now first degree murder carries a life
sentence in iowa
rivera who on the stand said two masked
men kill tidbits and put her body in his
car
plans to appeal for cbs this morning
saturday
adriana diaz chicago